foreign
[Applause]
so this is set to the tune of this old
man cause you're old it's free also
this old man he got mad for Obama and it
made us glad in a sketch on this show
it's called key and peel then he won an
Emmy and he's a really big deal
[Applause]
[Music]
this old man he's Mr key he's got a
beard and it's very funny and he makes
us laugh so hard that maybe we
yeah let's all sing Happy Birthday on
three one
one two
two
happy birthday to you
happy birthday
dear Keegan
Happy Birthday to you
[Applause]
a happiest birthday thank you thank you
so much
for all the joy and happiness that you
have brought to the world thank you drew
this was so special this is really
lovely and I get to see Ross
look at this we got the candle and
everything and that one candle for that
one special wish all right well think
about narratives right now right
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
you go so as I've been talking to Amazon
and throwing this out all right brother
Super Mario Brothers movie is in
theaters now and should make it do in
season two is now streaming on Apple TV
Plus
Wednesday
[Music]